welcome everyone to the theory session I
hope it's not going to be too
theoretical my name is Benedict and I am
a quantitative analyst by profession
because I'm always stumbling about this
word I'm just saying I'm a quant who of
you knows what a quant us Oh awesome
I didn't expect that people told me if
you go to Berlin with this topic nobody
will understand anything that apparently
is not true for those who don't know
what a quant does my job is to implement
models for the valuation of structured
financial products into software so I'm
kind of a software developer I work with
c-sharp in our company but I'm also
responsible for these models so in that
sense I'm closer to a data scientist but
then we don't do something like
predictive modeling but we have very
specific types of models which we call
replication models and so we're kind of
a different branch and today's topic is
about the valuation of call rights or
exercise rights making the right
exercise decisions and I've tried to
pare this down to as little financial
background as possible you can tell me
later if I succeeded with this my agenda
looks like this I intend to give you an
example what all rights
exercise rights are and work this
example through the valuation we're
going to do valuation by a simulation
Monte Carlo for those of you who know
about it I'm going to present to you the
long stuff Schwarz algorithm which is a
very nice approximation algorithm for
the valuation of call rights and for the
determination of exercise decisions and
if I can manage I'll go a little bit
broader in the end so what is a call
right a couple of weeks ago I went
through my closet and I found this on
the on the left here that is a gold coin
half a Krugerrand
and I don't know what you would do if
you found such a coin in your closet and
you had forgotten about it for years
first thing I did I check what it's
worth so 680 euros and I said wow that's
more than a PyCon cool then again I I
remembered the coin and you know it's a
gift from my grandfather so I'm a bit
sentimental about it so I'm not just
gonna cash it in and I want to keep it
then I looked at the gold prize of the
last months and the value of the coin
and you see how it increased fairly well
during the last months so that's good
for me but of course I don't know about
the future so what is my gold coin going
to be worth in a year in two years or
whatever so if you want to answer that
question first thing you do is you
create a model so of course I do a
simulation model because that is the
simplest thing to do that is you have
the time axis and you have the coin
value you start from 608 euros and then
you go into the future and you simulate
possible scenarios that this coin value
might take in the future so for example
if you look at the blue line we're
starting at 680 euros and say in five
years it ends up at 7725
so that's a good scenario for me but of
course there could also be bad scenarios
like the orange line where I ended up at
670 euros so each of these scenarios we
call paths gives me one possible view
for the future now you can go up it can
go down what is it that I want first of
all I want to keep my coin because I'm
sentimental about it second if the gold
price goes up and the coin value goes up
I want to participate in that
of course that's cool more value but if
the coin value Falls I don't want to
lose anything so you might say benedict
you cannot have all that but I say yes I
can
okay I have to pay for that and this is
the essential question about this talk
how much do I have to pay for that so
I'm not going to explain to you how I
will manage to get all these things done
and we're going to set a contract a
contract between you and me it works
like this I can pick any day during the
next five years and I'm going to tell
you at that day please pay me the
difference between six hundred and
eighty euros and the coin value at that
day so if the value is X then you will
have to pay me six hundred eighty euros
minus X specifically let's say the coin
value drops to six hundred and ten euros
you're going to have to pay me six
hundred eighty minus six hundred ten is
seven euros I can do so once and only
once
but I can pick any day during the next
five years so what I now have is a call
right or exercise right I have the right
to do so I don't have to you have to pay
the difference you you don't have a
right I have the right so and if you
want to get fancy the specific name for
this is an American put option if you
want to put something on top of that
it's a cash-settled American put option
remember that for tonight you can show
off so for you this is a really bad
contract because anything you can do in
the future is lose money so you will
definitely want me to pay a premium T to
you today and I'm going to show you how
to calculate the value of that premium
how to evaluate this option so let's
formalize it a little bit more we now
have the coin value on the x-axis and we
have the option pay off on the y-axis
now if the coin value is above 600 euros
680 euros I will not exercise so there's
not going to be any pay off at all
and if the coin value is below I might
exercise let's assume I do so and let's
assume the coin value as is at 610
then I'm going to receive 680 - 610
equals 7 euros so if you want to express
that as a formula that means what I get
from the option is the maximum of 680
minus X which is the current price then
and 0 ok let's check if this works out
for me so first of all whatever the
scenario is I get to keep my coin of
course we don't mess with the coin
second if the coin value Rises I want to
participate well as the option does not
pay off anything to me but also I don't
have to pay anything payoff is just zero
my future value will be X and that by
assumption is larger then it's 680 euros
I made money that's good if the coin
value Falls to some value X I don't want
to lose anything now the option pays off
680 minus X which I add to the to X
which is the coin value at that time
then I end up at 600 80 euros again you
made up for the difference I'm all good
because I am back at 680 so this setup
of the American put option works gives
me all my requirements now however I am
tasked with a very difficult decision
and that decision is should I exercise
my option or should I not let's look at
it from a time point of view if at any
day where the coin value is above 680
euros I have no decision to make because
it doesn't make any sense but on a day
where the coin value is below 680 euros
I have to decide do I stay in the
contract or do I exercise it once I have
exercised it it's gone it's over so I
have to optimize for me how to do that
and you have to determine how much I
should pay to you now so what we need
for this to to calculate the
that I have to pay to you we need the
concept of risk-neutral valuation this
is very broad topic I'm not going to get
into this we're going to do it very
simple let's take our model from before
each of these paths valuation works like
this you take the value that you see on
the very right like those seven hundred
twenty five seven ten you add them all
up divide them by the number of paths
you calculate the average and what you
get out of that is the price of course
it's a simulation based model so
everything has a margin and it's not
going to be perfectly exact but the more
pass you have the better you get so
that's how valuation works in principle
we need another concept and we need this
other concept for the decision-making
that I have to choose I am tasked with a
question when to exercise so I will
formulate two types of values type
number one is the exercise value that is
what I get when I exercise the coin the
second thing is the second value is the
continuation value that's the value I
get by not exercising by keeping staying
in the contract and the the question is
now at what point in time does my
continuation value it does my exercise
value get larger than the continuation
value you can said that day I will
exercise of course there may be several
days on which this is favorable but I
care about the first one so in this case
the first favorable exercise state is
what matters to me so these two values
have to be computed one of them is easy
one of them is hard exercise value is
very simple you just plug in the the
model simulated model passed into the
payoff function payoff function is
maximum of 680 minus X and 0 there you
plug in the simulated values and you get
the picture on the very right the
continuation value however is
and not simple um and there are several
approaches to that I will show you two
which don't work first of all I thought
well that's a simple thing I got my past
I know the future I can just compute the
continuation value by looking into the
future so let's say we are today at call
right and in order to know what my call
right is worth what the continuation
value is on that very path I just look
into the future and then see what what
it's worth that is approximately akin to
buying Google stocks in 2004 when it was
worth 50 bucks when you know that in
2019 it will be worth 1,200 okay that's
looking into the future
you can do that you can model that but
then you will heavily overvalue your
call right so not a good approach
unfortunately what we would need instead
is an expected value on that day so what
we could do is the concept of nested
simulation that means that for each path
we perform another simulation going into
the future the problem is for each path
I'm going to do another let's say 1,000
paths for the future so I'm already at
1,000 squared if you add another call
right at some other point in time then I
will be at 1,000 cube and so on so with
a number of call rights I'm growing
exponentially here and that is not good
so for anything practical like my
five-year running American option is
completely impossible for computational
reasons it would be correct but it
doesn't work so I'll show you the third
option
I will approximate my continuation value
I am going to take each and every path
and I'm going to approximate the value
they call a continuation value at Mike
all right time by a function I'm going
to take the information of all paths and
I'm going to average out the individual
information of each
so looking at it from this perspective
what you see now here is the coin value
at time t minus 1 on the x axis and the
continuation value on the y axis so this
looks like the payoff chart you've seen
before but with a little bit of noise
added because it's the point it's the
next point in time I may now not use
each particular point because that would
be looking into the future that would be
a perfect foresight instead I'm going to
approximate it using a polynomial
function in this case don't worry too
much about which function to use for now
I'll just use a second degree polynomial
what I do now is to average out the
information of each individual path to a
common expectation and that means I'm
not looking into the future anymore
this is a sound approach so I'll take a
short digression how do you do
curve fitting polynomial fitting in lump
I I was actually very surprised to see
that I don't need any side pie for this
it's just playing numpy there is a numpy
polynomial package and it has a nice
polynomial class and all you need to do
is to say polynomial fit give it the
degree that you like and it's going to
spit out a polynomial if you're in two
orthogonal pallone polynomials you can
do Legendre Locke Walsh and all the
stuff that is so available everything in
the package calculate one polynomial
from the other very nice so if you
forget anything else I'm telling you
today look into numpy polynomial that's
cool okay so we get everything ready now
and to talk about the long stuff what's
algorithm and this is the most code
heavy slide I do have
so first of all we have our simulated
values X these are all the paths
simulated in through the future first
dimension is the time second dimension
other number of paths and we do have a
strike value this is in case of the
option it's 680 euros I just made it
simple here just set it to one so we're
now going to do we were now going to
walk backwards in time starting at the
very right or at the very end first
we're going to take the cash flow that
that is realized if I exercise the
option on the very last day exactly at
five years from now so that's just the
payoff of the option maximum strike
minus X and zero that is cash flow so
now I'm moving backwards from this very
last point in time to closer to today
and I'm first going to compute the
exercise value on the day that is simple
as I said just plug in into the M into
the payoff function and then I'm going
to look at each and every path that is
in the money and the money means I can
exercise the option its value its payoff
would be larger than zero and I take out
all these paths on which I can exercise
and then fit a polynomial of my coin
value against the cash flow from next
time so this fitted variable that you
see here this is the one thing that
carries all the information about my my
approximated continuation value this is
the the core thing of this algorithm so
fit it now as an umpire instance of a
polynomial that means I can just call it
like any function and I'm going to apply
it to all the values that I've simulated
on that day there is something
interesting about this if you look at at
the evaluation that takes place here I
only care about the values that I've
used for
so in a way I don't use that polynomial
to interpolate or extrapolate anything
I'm going to do just in sample
evaluation of it
that means all I care about in this case
is that it has a functional form and I
have averaged out information that's a
bit unusual usually you want to do
interpolation or something if you do
curve fitting but in this case we don't
so and now I have to make the decision
which path has a continuation value that
is larger than the exercise value and
which doesn't and based on that I make
my exercise decision do I exercise do I
not I calculate the resulting cash flow
from that and I move on to the next
state so this is how the long stuff
Schwarz algorithm works it's the
simplest way I could possibly formulate
it I've even discarded discounting here
so it's yeah I don't think you can do it
any simpler if you know a way just tell
me I'm interested in that if you want to
have that in practice of course it would
be more complicated let's look at a
couple of steps that we create using
this algorithm so what you have here now
is the approximated continuation value
that's the blue line so that's a
polynomial in this case degree two and
you see all the results in cash flows
and you see wherever my exercise value
is above the blue line so you see a red
X then I'm going to exercise if it is
below it's going to be great
so here most are above the above blue
lines so we're going to exercise a lot
this is that I think this is the last
time point before the end if we move
closer to today it's changing you
already see that there are less points
where I will exercise if we move even
closer you will see none of them left so
this is at one and a half years so here
now exercise is actually feasible let's
look at
this on the time axis this is what the
algorithm generates for us
so each gray point is a simulated value
where it's not favorable to exercise and
each red X is a point where the
algorithm suggested to exercise the
option so you can see them all at the
bottom and more to the right intuitively
that makes sense the more the option
pays off the more likely it should be
for me to to exercise now you remember I
can exercise only once so if I have
multiple paths and I only ever care
about the first suggested exercise on
that path that's what I have in this
chart here so you see less XS because
the ones that happen later are now
ignored you see those paths are
described as a dashed line because I
have stopped the option I've exercised
it already and these are the points
where I will make my exercise decision
okay so now we get both things first of
all you know how much you have to charge
me and second I know when to exercise
you have the good fortune that your
estimate for the option value is pretty
good I have the disadvantage that my
exercise decision is absolutely awful
because if you look at those points they
look totally random and the problem here
is that which is using an approximation
algorithm there is no exact solution
I've tried to come up with an exact
solution for the simple case in this
simple case it's actually possible by
other means and it should look something
like the Green Line so the in a perfect
world we were not using X approximation
I would get an exercise decision below
the green line and I've offered a
wouldn't and you see the algorithm is
telling me something completely
different so you may wonder given that I
get shitty exercise decisions how can
the evaluation be good and the answer is
if you're in that area where the
nation is very close to the exercise
value so we're I'm nearly indifferent
between the two it doesn't make that
much of a difference by definition so it
is not this terrible if I make the wrong
decision in that sense so the good thing
is here these arrows average out and I
still get a pretty good valuation okay
so if you want to have something more
complex then an American put option you
don't get such a green line from any
other model anymore then actually
approximation is the only thing you can
do and that's why monster Falls is very
relevant if you do more complex call
rights usually you might not have an in
the money path or in the money concept
and you just do the approximation on all
paths if your payoff depends on more
than a single variable for example in
interest rates then you have to simulate
multiple variables that's still easy if
your payoff is path dependent meaning
for example you get the payoff that it
depends on the average of the past
something like that also we call it non
Markovian payoffs then you can still do
this
it still works that's actually the cool
thing about this algorithm or a Monte
Carlo approach is in general just you
can still work out more complex payoffs
if you do this in general yeah you'd
have to have to do a lot of work you
have to do a payoff and call write
description language which is actually
speaking from experience a very
complicated topic you have to create
risk neutral valuation models that is
all these distributions that I've
simulated without telling you you have
to calibrate these models and then the
exercise algorithm comes in now this is
a pretty hefty stuff but that's why
banks have daiquan departments so you'd
probably never do this but what you can
do
is to first look at this original paper
it's very accessible it has a first
chapter that is called numerical example
which explains the whole algorithm by
showing you tables of numbers where this
is just executed and what you can do is
second is to look up these slides and
also a jupiter notebook accompanying it
and also creating well I've created a
small Python package that has an
implementation of this algorithm which
is a little bit more general okay so
this is what I wanted to show you I'm
now ready for Q&A thank you very much oh
thank you for the talk if I understood
it right it's very essential that your
Monte Carlo simulation is somewhat
realistic right and I guess basically
the essence of machine learning and data
science is that from the past
observation you can extrapolate in the
future but does that apply to financial
markets do they behave in the future
like they did in the past are they
actually predictable so can you comment
on that it is a very good question and
the answer is a clear no you cannot
extrapolate and those past I've shown
you they don't correspond to past
realizations of the of the gold price
but rather they are implied expectations
of the market so what you do is a
concept of calibration against market
instruments that already look into the
future that are traded in a liquid
market for example European options and
from these you kind of get back the
expectation that the market has about
the future you can get an implied
distribution of future stock price gold
price whatever and then you create a
model that fits this expectation so kind
of a really question of that so it's
going to be October 31st soon and
and Rex it's gonna happen and my
prediction is that all time series
models will probably fail there's
something we said also here right the
uncertainties should skyrocket around
that time how do you accommodate for
these sorts of moments because you can
probably pinpoint a couple of moments in
time when the uncertainty should be
super sky high
yes actually that was historically
speaking before the brexit vote happened
there was something very interesting
happening with options on the euro
British Pound spot so what you could see
that up to that point the uncertainty
was rising this uncertainty that is
implied by the market expectation and
and before on the day of the vote it was
on top and then afterwards of course
everybody knew then the Pound dropped so
yes you can observe this in implied
volatilities of options and you have to
accommodate for that by calibrating to
these options so you can never work with
time series models here that extrapolate
the past it doesn't work yeah it's
exactly proxy it's kind of a proxy it is
a market expectation
thanks for to talk very much I was
already dusted out and you told us that
you get the expectation from what is
already traded but that sounds a bit
like the market would expect something
and then it realizes because the market
expects it is it like that like this in
in a way yes yeah so we're using we just
we're extrapolating in a different space
here if you will so we have we have
options not the American options but the
European options with just a single
payoff date and then we use that
information to to calibrate and then
from the models we come using the models
we compute the value of more complex
products so this is the the way it works
this is not the same thing as
statistical fits that's something
completely different and what you do is
you replicate the prices of liquid
instruments in the market you
in your model you have to fit these if
you don't fit these you know or you
already know what that you're wrong but
then using that model and you compute
the prices of more complex products and
the question is does that work well it
does but it's actually kind of the
middle between science and arts yeah so
there's a lot going on the funny thing
is if you trade products then based on
that you will quickly realize whether
you're right or wrong because if you're
wrong with your price and then you're
going to get priced out of the market
you're going to lose a lot of money
that's why banks have Korn departments
we only have time for a very short
question is it sure good is the answer
short yeah thanks I'll keep it short so
from my understanding following the
market as you say isn't that primarily
if you have a market maker strategy
would this also apply to proprietary
trading desk in what sense do you mean
would it apply that you sort of estimate
the expectation from the market and then
act upon those expectations rather than
having your own strategies that could be
arbitrage ah okay I see your point now
this assumes that there is no of the
arbitrage so you're taking the point
that you cannot beat the market you
assume the market is always right and
you're less smart than the market yeah
yeah now I see when it doesn't apply
there yes thank you very much
please following questions you can do it
afterwards let's think
[Applause]